on Monday 380 sheriff's representing 40
states announced that they had sent a
letter to every member of Congress
calling for legislation that includes
president Trump's border wall joining us
now for reaction is the sheriff who
spearheaded that letter Bristol County
Massachusetts Sheriff Tom Hudson and
also Jose Arista Moneo who's a former
deputy press secretary for the DNC is in
Miami Jose I thought you're gonna be
here in studio with me now you're way
over there in Miami what fun is that
that's good to see both of you let's
talk about let's talk about this issue
it's a sticky issue it's a controversial
issue but sheriff let's start with you
380 sheriffs now there are a lot of
sheriffs across this country but that's
not an insignificant number saying the
border wall is necessary but we got
congressmen and Senators in Washington
who say censors and partial double
fencing and other technology drones that
will be enough along with additional
manpower to secure this border sir well
first of all these are these are people
who are sitting in Washington spend most
of their time under the dome there who
have little knowledge about what's
happening on the border and what the
terrain is and so forth look it's gonna
be there are going to be some some cyber
things there'll be some some you know
visual posts there but the wall is it
absolutely critical to keep people from
getting into this country as easily as
they're coming in now and they've been
flooding in by the thousands as you know
Jose I want to go to you on this
drew Murdoch a few years ago columnist
for the New York Post wrote a piece
listing the the illegal aliens who are
caught at the border this was back in
the year 2015 and it's good it's not
we're not talking about Mexicans or
Guatemalans or Salvadorans we're talking
about people from countries that were
labeled by President Obama as terror
havens and this is what they found this
isn't 2015 Border Patrol defected
detained from Iran 154 Sudan 81 Syria 57
and from Cuba then designated terror
terrorist country 2281
and then countries of interest included
Afghanistan Algeria Iraq Lebanon Libya
Nigeria Pakistan Saudi Arabia 276 Somali
131 Yemen 71 this is a national security
issue is it not at the border it's a
national security issue Lauren but we
have to be clear on something and it's
this the only way that we're actually
gonna solve this the only way that we're
actually gonna get the real criminals we
are at the point let me be clear anybody
in this country who see who's who is
undocumented who has committed serious
crimes they need to be deported we the
way that we do that is by passing
comprehensive immigration reform let's
actually get there undocumented
immigrants were good people let's get
them out of the shadow okay let's put
them into our system and that would
actually allow people like the sheriff
to actually go after the bad guys so
that's what we got to do it yeah so
you're saying the people who are illegal
immigrants today in the United States
are in the shadows because I see them at
rallies I see them at protests I see
them at congressman's offices I saw them
at the State of the Union I don't see
that a lot of people that shut they're
outside at Walmart they're getting jobs
I mean they're working some are daca
members a doctor here but so there are a
lot of people who are not in the shadows
any longer they're not really Muslim I
don't think are all their prey to be
lured are there well look they're
certainly in the shadow economy even
though they pay taxes right but I think
we you and I would agree that a lot of
employers are abusing these immigrants
they're they're taking by paying them
very little money there are absolutely
very little money and they're in
laundering the lives of illegal
immigrants crossing the border because
they think they can get a job that's
endangering their lives I'm gonna go
back to the sheriff you and I yeah well
we're back in one second Sheriff you you
heard what Jose said what we need is a
comprehensive reform this wall thing is
a big waste of money and it's not people
will climb over any wall you put there
you react look you'll never you'll never
have comprehensive immigration reform
until you deal with the security
shoots at the border it's not going to
happen and by the way this idea of
people coming out of the shadows and you
need them to report crimes it's all
that's that's a false narrative but more
to the point is you have people who
approach sanctuary saying bring these
people out of the shadows give them a
protective bubble so nobody can identify
who they are particularly there be
criminal illegals in there as well and
then at the same time you got Becerra
out in California saying you law-abiding
citizens you business owners if you dare
to cooperate with ice and work with law
enforcement to keep your communities and
your business is safe we're gonna
prosecute you so we want you to go into
the shadows and not report anything it's
outrageous and it's ridiculous and it's
completely unamerican and it undermines
the sheriff's and all the other law
enforcement community across this
country when we're trying to keep people
safe Jose I think one thing that
Americans can't get their minds wrapped
around in California is such a beautiful
state it's an amazing place and I took
the California Bar years ago wanted to
live there loved the state but it's an
odd thing is it not when business owners
who are paying a lot of taxes a lot of
regulations in California they're
actually made out to be the bad guys
when they cooperate with ice or they
simply report to ice or they allow ice
to come in and examine their workplace I
mean they're the bad guys
and then the illegal immigrants who were
released back into society they're
coddled they're protected sometimes to
go and maim or kill or rape or commit
other crimes again so that's the dynamic
I think people who aren't even political
think wait a second are they on our side
well they're consider syns and legal
immigrants side or are they on illegal
immigrant side look I understand that
the debate but the only you don't fix
that by building a wall that it is a
waste of money you fix it by actually
passing some sort of reform into the
immigration system man let me let me say
something on the wall
well let me say let me speak share like
with all due respect let me just finish
my poem here or something something that
you said something that you said under
President Barack Obama we put more boots
on the ground than any other prior
precedent in the history of this country
so we've been trying to do this we've
been trying to actually secure the
border and report
it's time and time again don't keep
their they don't they don't keep meto
keep their end of our thoughts they
don't keep it under problems I'd like to
play a sound buy this is Brandon Judd
from the Border Patrol Council who was
on our show last week let's watch I just
finished my shift a couple hour hours
ago patrolling the border I speak with
hundreds of agents on a daily basis and
all of those agents are telling me we
need walls and strategic locations and
we're gonna prove that we need those
walls that's those the guys actually
with the boots on the ground Jose
they're there and he said they're
literally parts of the border you can
just walk right across right near the
Rio Grande just walk right across
there's no barrier there's just a bunch
of you know a tumbleweeds I guess but
there's there's no barrier he'll just
walk right across and they do it's a
national security issue and an economic
issue and a humanitarian issue all
wrapped into one
I agree in there but there are better
ways to do it there are way better ways
to do it with technology with drones
with people on the ground there we don't
need to waste money on the one you know
what let me say one more thing on the
wall really quickly instead of building
a fixed physical wall with Mexico I got
an idea why don't we we build a cyber
wall with Russia
that's the real threat not Mexico let's
look to the other side I love the fact
that you know Jose I've got to say I'm
actually gonna salute you for getting
the Russia referencing that is like a
that's like a camel sit spin like at a
triple lutz in a in a backflip on the
ice all combined Sheriff Larry quickly
Laura while we're talking about
different parts of the world just look
at Israel look they they don't they have
a combination of cyber stuff they have
they have balloons in the air they have
they have watch stations you have to
have a combination of things but we have
to have a wall and this idea of just
create comprehensive reform is not going
to stop people for coming through I've
been on the border now three times and I
watched from an aerial surveillance a
guy in the middle of the day take a
yellow raft he's halfway across he hears
the plane up above looks up at a
scurries back over and he was going to
be back over across that border as soon
as we left and this is a reorganization
sheriff that he looked up and waved and
said hi see how the others he did like
he did but he didn't use this whole hand
when he waved
I pray oh I got you sheriff Hodgins it's
great to see both of you thanks so much
have a great Easter weekend